RULES COMMITTEE FOR TUESDAY MAY
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE BE
ADVISED ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE
THERE ARE RIO YEAH YEAH YEAH.
HE SENT YEAH NUMBER YEAH MY
NAME MATHIS HERE QUIRK SILVA
HERE RAMOS VERY RIVAS. WHERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY WE HAVE A
AND WE HAVE A AGENDA. WHICH
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER I'D
LIKE TO RESPECT REQUEST WE
REMOVE ITEMS TO AN SEVEN
CONSENT THOSE ARE THE URGENCY
REQUEST FOR. AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE AND A. B. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY SIX RESPECTIVELY. VERY
GOOD THAT WILL BE THE ORDER WE
WILL TAKE THEM UP SEPARATELY.
IS OUR MOST ON THE REMAINDER OF
THE CONSENT AGENDA. MOVE BY-
THERE'S COM LOCKER SECONDED BY
MS CARILLO. MATTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE GRAYSON THE
PERSON I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER AYE
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA. FOR SILVA
IRA MOST. RAMOS IRATE READER.
RIVAS I MOTION PASSES MOST OF
PASS IS OUR MOTION ON EITHER
NUMBER TWO TWO YEARS AGO
REQUEST FOR A BI FOUR THREE
READ AND I'D NUMBER SEVEN YEARS
COVER FOR A THIRTY SIXTY SIX.
AUTHORED BY JUST REGULAR MOVE
BY A RAMOS THEIR SECOND. SANTA
BROUGHT CARILLO MATTER SEARCH
CALL ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY I.
CUNNINGHAM NO CARILLO RIO I.
LARA KNOW GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I LIVE LIVING
I MET. MATHIS DOWN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS RAMOS I
READ. RIVERSIDE MOTION BY THAT
MOST CRASH AND OF THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS A JURY THANK YOU
MUCH.